pas un mot mais son regard en dit long
thomas thévenoud ressort de la cour
d'appel de paris condamné pour fraude
fiscale
un an de prison avec sursis et trois ans
d'inéligibilité
c'est moins que les réquisitions mais
plus que la peine prononcée en première
instance le 29 mai dernier l'ex député
de saône-et-loire avait écopé de trois
mois de sursis et une année
d'interdiction de se présenter comme
candidat à une élection
le parquet avait fait appel de cette
décision l' affaire remonte au 4
septembre 2014 secrétaire d'état au
commerce extérieur thomas thévenoud et
chassé du gouvernement après la
révélation de ces négligences fiscale il
aurait été ministres seulement neuf
jours
un coup de tonnerre d'autant que le
bourguignon avait fait de la lutte
contre la fraude fiscale son cheval de
bataille
cette condamnation pourrait donc
signifier la fin de cette affaire très
médiatique
les écoutes evenou peuvent cependant
décidé de se pourvoir en cassation